[Music]
hello Jubilee and all the goo team is
out there in Portland
at the moment what's really scary to me
is the fact that no one really knows how
to handle the whole situation and we
lived paycheck to paycheck
I was afraid what I don't know what's
coming in the future uncertainty
uncertainty uncertainty this is the
longest that I've really had to spend
with my thoughts I have recognized some
self-destructive behaviors I myself own
struggle with depression and I'm home
and there's no people around me I really
don't have a good way to distract myself
our family life hasn't been well melding
together and I'm emotionally breaking
down where I work it's insane at 6:30
a.m. there's people already waiting
outside and it's ridiculous we're
literally risking our lives for for this
suppose you fell I've seen a disturbing
rise and hate-filled attacks right now
I'm most afraid about my own health
because I have like underlying condition
I have a chronic autoimmune illness I
also have type 1 diabetes I'm missing
all over my lung
if I could possibly die my parent my dad
my sister I have a newborn baby brother
I'm on earth my dad is still working and
his company won't give him a leave my
dad has a history with cancer I had a
mom
he is immunocompromised
what am I most afraid of right now it's
my loved ones getting sick and
particularly my boyfriend getting sick
because he's got a lot of health issues
that really put him at a high risk
because Carly my mom still is working I
wish she could like stay home stay home
not have to work so hard because I could
sacrifice not graduating but I couldn't
really like sacrifice my family right
before I started recording this video my
grandpa was shipped off the hospital I
called my dad about five days ago and
and apparently he had been sick for
quite some time and he didn't tell me
but he got tested and it turns out he
was positive for kovat 19 it's so
different when you can literally hear
the shortness of someone's breath
through the phone
I have a lot of questions in my head you
don't get to just stay with them to see
them get better or you didn't get to say
goodbye
you just see a number
[Music]
you didn't get to celebrate who they
were you didn't get to to show you how
much you love them what's your focus I'm
just gonna focus for now there is a
white blanket hanging outside it's a
sign of we unite with the caregivers and
as you can see it there are people out
here on the window so every day here at
8:00 every night at 10 o'clock 6 p.m. at
8 o'clock to Mum so very cool definite
ear I could there's this scientists and
researchers the people who are
endangering their own life truck driver
and the grocery store worker the unsung
heroes San Diego Girl Scouts answered
the call knowing homemade masks so many
people who don't have anything to do
with each other I have now something
they share that's I think had has kind
of strange beauty
the fact how much we still grasp to life
even if that is just walking the streets
that we knew so well the fact that we
still want to laugh to smile to see
people live to enjoy life even if we're
in our houses
[Music]
[Applause]
there's more active resilience in the
unity that I feel with my my fellow
citizens
[Music]
you